[Musique]
pour la partie chorégraphique de ce
spectacle Maurice beéard a délégué une
de ses danseuses maté souverbi que l'on
voit ici dans un extrait de l' exquise
comédie balai inspiré de la Veuve
[Musique]
Joyeuse
autre Vette à l'ffiche de ce spectacle
Jacques
[Musique]
duutroncquron c'est la première fois que
vous passé dans la région parisienne oui
enfin non comment ça non j'ai déjà fait
qu mê oui mais la formule du trp
c'est-à-dire avec une première partie
avec les ballets de Béjard qui va
m'amener à vous demander ce que vous
pensez de Béjard et de maté
sousverdi je préfère parler de de maté
parce que ou je pu quand même
l'apercevoir elle ouais c'est c'est
gênant quand même parce que tous les
soirs je l'aperçois seulement derrière
un petit rideau ça je peux pas bien
apprécié mais je pense qu'un qu'un soir
je vais pouvoir m'offrir une place quand
même 1 2 1 2 3
[Musique]
4 en 5 7 je vois mon blanc sec à toute
bom
je àin
jeanteb souverb passz dans le spectacle
de Dutron est-ce que vous voyez le
spectacle de Duron est-ce que vous avez
le temps est-ce que vous pouvez je vois
non je vois très peu de choses
que je passe de fois dans la première
partie et je ne reste pas chaque soir
pour voir du Tron j'aime beaucoup et
cette formule spectacle de balai en
première partie et variété en seconde
partie vous êtes pour que ça continue
vous trouvez ça bien oui c'est très dur
c'est très dur
[Musique]
très
une question que je voulais vous
demander j' est-ce que vous êtes timide
oui oui poly est timide mais est-ce que
en scène cette timidité disparaît ou se
transforme en trque ah non non c'est
c'est la même chose non timidité et
trque c'est totalement différent
expliquez-moi la
différence TR on a peur et la timidité
c'est on a peur aussi non non non la
réserve pe c'est un peu de honte c'est
pas de la peur c'est de la discrétion
mais je
pas mais ne croyez pas qu'avec les
filles je suis une cocote
minut car en véritévec les filles je
suis un
[Musique]
COC dans un self
Chav dans un snack je vois mon cognac
dans les drogues c'est là que je
drague
mais ne croyez pas qu'avec les filles je
sois une
minute car en vérité avec les filles je
suis un COC minut en moin de Ju je te
veux en de temps je fais TR mouvements
en 5 plus à de
sec je suis pr pr
pr vite trop vite je doiser ça
[Musique]
ésité